[Musique]
le président du département cyrille
melchior et le maire de saint-leu bruno
domaine ont signé ce vendredi 12
novembre un nouveau pacte de solidarité
territoriale
un montant de près de 5 millions d'euros
l'investissement est doublé par rapport
à la première génération
je suis à saint leu comme vous le voyez
quoi signer avec le meilleur le pacte de
solidarité territoriale
pst2 il y en a eu un rôle à signer en
2018 et bien aujourd'hui on va signer le
deuxième acte de solidarité qui
représente un peu plus de 3 millions
d'euros en investissement doit aider la
ville de saint leu ben à sa ménagère à
conçoit des équipements de proximité
sécuriser les roues améliorée des
équipements sportifs des équipements
culturels dans tous ces domaines mais
aussi il ya six cent mille euros de
prévu pour les actions sociales
l'accompagnement des repas pour les
gramounes par exemple que le ccas de
saint leu a mis en place et bien le
département de la réunion apporte des
financements mais président et le maire
se sont ensuite rendus à stella où a
débuté la construction du foyer de
l'enfance de l'ouest faisant
symboliquement posé la première pierre
de cette nouvelle structure accompagnée
par la sous préfète de saint paul
se maintenant à cette première pierre
son fruit une enfance y faire kiva
premiers dans l'ouest jusque là une dans
le sud est une langue première premier
équipement ici
cela cuir -2 7 mike yvonne maïs yeux sur
ce dont il convenir d'une scène de la
rai la ville nous a mis à disposition le
terrain à l'euro symbolique et nous
fallait avoir ce terrain va pouvoir
lancer le projet un an et demi de
travail pour les entreprises bayonnais
c'est aussi à saluer et en quoi une fois
dedans au mois d'avril 2023 nous aurons
le plaisir d'inaugurer ce grand bâtiment
qui va accueillir près de 40 ans en dari
au programme également la visite du
futur giratoire du bricoleur à portail
un échangeur qui doit désengorger la
circulation du quartier du pit au lait
comme pour chacune de ses visites le
président du département implanté avec
les élus des espèces endémiques dans le
cadre du plan un million d'arbres une
séquence particulière au jardin
botanique de la réunion avec la
présentation de la banque de semences
départementale
la banque des semences on n'en veut pas
des dizaines pourquoi pas ce qu'il faut
de la traçabilité on veut savoir
l'origine bien sûr bad et des graines
comment serena sont arrivés ici donc il
faut les répertorier il faut les
préparer et il nous faut cette banque de
semences parce que pour arriver à un
million d'arbres mes amis et bien il en
faut des plans et bien et nous faut
d'abord des graines et bien la banque de
semences et ça c'est de recueillir
toutes les semences de toute l'île de
les préparer pas être mise en terre la
vie du jardin botanique comprenait aussi
une présentation du plan de valorisation
de la rose pour bon et des roses
anciennes par le département en
partenariat avec l'association des
jardins créoles lui hpr l'armée flore et
la chambre d'agriculture
[Musique]